the grand chest tour was the brainchild  of Gary Kasparov he was able to connect  a lot of organizers and players and  sponsors to create what is the best  circuit of chess events that has existed  or will exist and I think we can expect  many more years of great events to come  with the grand chessboard used to say  when people talked about Soviet chess  school he liked his heart because he  said it was not about the country was  more about spirit and he said the best  represent of Soviet chess school in 1970  was Bobby Fischer  every time I fly from New York and lose  I had this nostalgic feelings and I  understood why because this is where the  spirit of chess is very much alive  nursing field cup champion for 2016  Grandmaster Wes Lisa